in the city of long beach
just south of los angeles a sprawling
convention center has been transformed
into a shelter for up to one thousand
migrant children
seeking asylum in the united states
inside there are toys games recreation
facilities and school classes
all meant to provide humane care and
lessen the trauma children feel after
making the long
dangerous journey to the u.s border the
mission
of this center here in long beach is
quick family reunification
the reunifications should be done as
fast as possible
and we also know that the space that we
are in
is temporary it is incredibly important
that in this moment
we treat every single child with
compassion
with kindness and with love the biden
administration has been under intense
political pressure to
deal effectively with the large numbers
of unaccompanied children
mostly from central america crossing the
border
the numbers have leveled off from a peak
of around 20
thousand miners in custody in march but
officials are pushing hard for the
children to be released to their parents
or other family quickly immigrant rights
advocates were allowed to examine the
facilities
what we saw with this center is that
number one
when they will walk in it will have a
sense of welcome
to reunite with their child parents must
show documentation
and give a dna sample after release the
child will have a hearing scheduled on
their application for asylum
most of those parents are also
undocumented but the biden
administration
pledges it will not target them for
deportation
if they come forward to claim their
children that's in sharp contrast with
the previous administration's attitude
toward migrant families
during the trump administration the
policy of that administration was if
parents came forward and they
were undocumented maybe a week or two
weeks later
immigration authorities would be at
their doorstep
so that had created a great level of
anxiety
and ambivalence advocates say ultimately
developmental aid to
impoverished central american countries
and an overhaul of u.s
immigration laws are the keys to
stabilizing the situation
so that in the future no child should
have to cross the border
alone rob reynolds al jazeera long beach
california